- But how did you come up
with the idea? The rapping?
How did you think that would sway them
and get better grades?
- So I've been teaching for
six years and it's always
a challenge every beginning
of the year and how to
engage and motivate the children.
- [Kelly] Mmhmm.
- So, this year I wanted to
incorporate free styling into it
because every single time I'd
give all my students free time
they'd go onto the computer
and look up beats and they'd
just go off and rap.
- That's so amazing.
(audience claps)
(laughs)
- I love that!
So Taj, you look very
handsome head to toe as well.
You look sharp right now.
Just letting you know.
But what do you think
about free style Fridays?
Do you like that?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- What I think about free style Friday is
that you get
to learn but you get to
play at the same time.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you get to have fun too.
And school should be fun.
It should be educational, it
should also be a good time
and implement both of
those things together.
You've a really great teacher right here
just letting you know.
Do you like rapping?
What do you rap about?
- Money (mumbles)
(clapping)
(audience laughs)
and...
- You said money, what?
- And beats and cars.
- And beats and cars and
school, all right. All right.
- Yes they do.
- I like it you know what you
want, you know what you like.
I'm a fan of it Taj.
So can any of y'all freestyle?
I can not rap for anything
everybody saw it on Billboard Awards.
- Can you freestyle?
- No, that's my greatest fear in life.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, I most definitely cannot.
- Bronc?
- [Woman] It's the free style that scares-
- My boy Bronc can do it though right?
- [Kelly] Can you rap?
- Hey-
- He can do it!
- Back in college at 2:00
AM, I was always rapping.
(laughs)
- Well at 2:00 AM, we all think
we are great at everything.
(laughs)
- One time my friend recorded me
and I was like, "Wow, I'm awful."
(audience laughs)
I thought I was like amazing
at that time, at that moment.
(laughs)
- I love you! Oh my God!
- I can hit a line, I can hit a line...
- Okay, do it.
♪ You think I'm a rapper.
I'm only a snapper. ♪
♪ I get in a fight, hit you in the face ♪
♪ make you a two gapper ♪
(audience cheers)
- Did you just make that up?
- Yah I just made it up.
- You just free styled that?
(laughs)
(audience claps)
- Okay, but we just want let Taj know
that hitting is not acceptable.
- No.
(laughs)
(claps)
- [Bronc] That was a bad message.
- [Kelly] No I'm just kidding.
Literally that's like my husband and I
we're like, "wait we said
that in front of them.
Okay, let's go back to we just said..."
(laughs)
cause they listen to everything.